a new trailer to the Wolverine we have
another Wolverine movement coming out
and let's try to get this one right
so if you're an x-men movie fan or an
x-men fan in general odds are you like
Wolverine just a badass character he's
damaged he's enraged he's indestructible
he has blades that come out of his hands
and he's played by Hugh Jackman let's be
honest with ourselves as long as Hugh
Jackman is alive and they're making a
movie about Wolverine he will play a
Wolverine so we actually have a couple
of Wolverine trailers we have a domestic
trailer for the USA and we have an
international trailer the International
trailer shows more of the action element
of the movie the domestic trailer shows
more of this ominous tone but both get
the same point across it shows Wolverine
he looks like Caviezel from passion we
have Jesus Christ with hand blade it's
an honor to meet the Wolverine
that's not who I am anymore
and he's kind of lost his way doesn't
know what he's living for he doesn't
even go by the Wolverine anymore and
this chick finds him and she's like my
employer wants to thank you
international trailer people are like oh
dude it's it's Jesus Christ with Han
blaze bust him in the face with a bottle
oh holy [ __ ] he's gonna oh yeah he's
gonna kick our ass who the Wolverine had
saved this Japanese dude World War two
from the bomb I haven't wanted to thank
you for saving my life that's right it's
official Wolverine is nuke proof even
the cockroaches got scorched by the
fallout but not the Wolverine and now
this dude's a really old rich guy and
he's like I want to help you immortality
it's not good it's a curse not a
blessing I can make you mortal and after
that I guess that happens because in
this trailer Wolverine has lost the
ability to heal before and I was like
it's not one of those mental things is
it like spider-man TV's like I don't
want to be spider-man anymore so I
magically am NOT spider-man anymore I
don't think it is because it does show
some procedures happening with him so
ultimately Wolverine becomes mortal he
is vulnerable and as the international
trailer states
pretty much when he's vulnerable he's a
badass the thing that the international
trailer does show more of that the
domestic doesn't is a silver samurai
schism throwing down with Wolverine I'm
like Wolverine fighting silver samurai
cool there's no other way to say like
what else you gonna say except that's
bad I want to see that right now one
question I do have is I'm like wait a
minute if that whole life-saving thing
happens back before he lost his memory
he wouldn't remember it then right is he
just like who are you old guy does he
think this guy's full of [ __ ] or is
he like oh cool yeah I'll go along with
it or is it like I totally remember that
because I don't have amnesia it takes
place after x-men 3 so I'm interested to
see like do they count x-men 3 is it
official lore about x-men origins
Wolverine does it count x-men origins
Wolverine are we gonna see things in
this movie that directly contradict
x-men origins Wolverine before to see an
x-men first class contradict x-men
origins Wolverine and x-men 3 these kind
of things I look for in movies as much
as he is an x-men character and has gone
through the x-men adventures you don't
feel like this is an x-men movie it's a
personal story about this guy who can't
die who suddenly becomes mortal and now
he has to deal with that [ __ ]
so the trailer or the trailers to the
Wolverine have you seen them what do you
think about and what wouldn't you like
better international trailer or domestic
trailer whatever you think whichever one
you like comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]